[music]
>> Point number 11.
For Dawah to be effective
there are basically three major
requirements according to me.
There are many requirements.
But according to me, for Dawah to be
very effective
there are three major requirements.
Number one
is
the help of Allah.
And Allah says in the Quran in Surah
Imran chapter number three verse number
that if Allah helps you, none can
overcome you.
And if Allah forsakes you, who is there
then who can help you? So let the
believers
put their trust in Allah. So number one
requirement
is the help of Allah.
The most important factor
not only for Dawah
for any Islamic activity.
Number one
is the help of Allah.
If a moment, if a believer, if a Muslim
realizes this that number one most
important factor is help of Allah
most of the good works he does,
inshallah, he'll find success in that.
Most important is Allah's help.
If Allah helps you, none can overcome
you. If Allah forsakes you, who is there
then who can help you? So let the
believers put their trust in Allah.
Number one factor
is
help of Allah.
If the help of Allah is not there, with
all your knowledge
with all your training
with all your experience
success rate
would be zero or close to it. Even if
you find success, it would be temporary
or it may take you more towards
not the benefit of your akhira.
So number one
for the success in anything including
this Dawah training workshop is the help
of Allah.
If Allah helps you,
none can overcome you. If Allah forsakes
you, then who is there who can help you?
And unfortunately, many Muslims, or most
of them, or almost all, when we really
seek help, we see who should we go to.
Okay, if I want this job, which is the
wasila, via media, who will I contact?
Yes.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala does
also see what is your passion, which is
the next verse.
But, the best who can help you is Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And the easiest
to reach
anyone in this world is Allah.
To reach Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
easier
than to reach anyone else in this world.
He may be a father, she may be a mother,
he may be a son, she may be a daughter.
No one is more easier to reach than
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
The best to help is Allah, and the
easiest to reach is Allah.
The second factor is dedication and hard
work.
Allah says in the Quran in Surah
Ankabut, chapter number 29, verse number
69, that if you strive in our cause,
we will open up our pathways. If you
strive and struggle, if you do jihad in
the way of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will open up
his path for you.
Allah promises in the Quran in Surah
Ankabut, chapter number 29, verse number
69, that if you strive and struggle,
Allah will open up your pathways.
If you strive and struggle, and if you
don't get success,
who's to blame? Allah promises if you
strive, he will give you success.
If you strive, and if you don't get
success, that means you have not strived
and struggled in the right way.
If you strive and struggle, Allah gives
you a promise, he will open up your
pathway. If you strive and struggle, if
you don't get success,
that means your striving and struggling
was not correct.
So, to get Allah's help,
Allah is showing you a way in the Quran
itself.
If Allah helps you, none can overcome
you. How do you get Allah's help?
Allah shows you in the Quran.
In Surah Ankabut, chapter number 29,
verse number 69. You strive in our
pathway, we will open up your pathway.
If you strive and struggle, you have to
get success.
If you do not strive and struggle in the
right way,
you may think you have got success,
but that's not the correct success.
Just for information,
there were candidates
till yesterday
supposed to attend this program.
Till yesterday,
when we realized that their striving and
struggling was not correct, we refused
to let them attend this program.
When we realized that the interview was
not
correct,
if a person is striving and struggling
in Allah's way,
there is no question whatsoever that
he'll not get success.
You may think, "Okay, fine. I have
fooled the person."
There may be people yet who are here,
but if his nia is not correct, it will
be exposed today or tomorrow.
Even if it's not exposed, it will be
exposed in the afterlife.
So, if you know that you are doing it
only for the sake of Allah
and Allah alone,
you are sure to get success and no one
you have to please except Allah.
So, number one for success in any good
work,
if it's amali saleh,
if it is a righteous deed, if it is a
good work,
seek for Allah's help.
If Allah helps you, none can overcome
you. You strive in the way of Allah,
Allah will open up your pathways.
The third requirement,
techniques
and knowledge.
Allah says in Surah Nahl, chapter number
16, verse 43.
And Surah Anbiya, chapter number 21,
verse 107.
If you don't know, ask the person who's
knowledgeable.
If you don't know something,
ask the person who's an expert. No one
in the world knows everything.
There is no harm at all
in
telling I don't know.
So, number three is technique.
If you don't know, ask the person
knowledgeable. And while you're seeking
for knowledge in a particular field, it
doesn't make a difference if that expert
is a Muslim or non-Muslim.
If you want to get something which is
there, even if a non-Muslim is expert,
you can learn from him.
Because he's expert in that field, and
that will help you.
So, according to me
and according to the Quran, the three
most important factors, number one is
Allah's help, and all three are
interlinked.
Number one is Allah's help. If Allah
helps you, none can overcome you. If
Allah forsakes you, who would then be
able to help you? So, let the believers
put their trust in Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala. Number two is strive in the way
of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
And these three points, Surah Ali Imran,
chapter number three, verse number 160.
If Allah helps you, none can overcome
you. If Allah forsakes you, who is there
then who can help you? So, let the
believers, let the moment put their
trust in Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
The second,
Surah Ankabut, chapter 29, verse 69.
If you strive in the way of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala,
Allah will open up your pathways. And
the third, if you don't know, ask the
one who's knowledgeable.
in kuntum la ta'lamun.
Surah Anbiya, chapter number 21 verse
number seven and Surah Nahl chapter 16
verse number 43. Even if you grasp these
three things properly
by the end of the training
that Allah alone is the one
if he helps you, you will again succeed
in this world and the hereafter and you
strive in the way of Allah. And if you
don't know, ask the person of knowledge
bill. Even if these three things you
grasp
I feel the training would be sufficient.
Many a time when people ask me
Dr. Zakir you know, you give such good
talks. What's the secret? So, I said
it's an open secret.
And I say first is Surah Ali Imran
chapter three verse 160. Allah's help is
required. Number two, you strive in the
way of Allah. Number three, it's
technique.
Immediately they ask, "What is the
technique?"
They should ask
"How do I get Allah's help?"
Almost all the Muslims the immediate
next question is "Dr. Zakir, what is the
technique?" They think I have a chip.
Wallah
all 19 of you
when you spoke on the stage just a
couple of hours before all of you were
100 times better than me when I started
my dawah. If you know my background, I
was a stammerer. I used to stutter.
So, all of you, alhamdulillah, are more
than 100 times better
than what I was when I started.
That means
if you follow these three things
you can become 100 times better than
what I am now.
But, the question is not what is the
technique. The question is how to get
Allah's help.
And this training program, inshallah,
you will realize
that what is not possible otherwise
normally with Allah's help
you can do wonders.
This training program, though
will be mainly focusing on the third
point.
Techniques
of public speaking.
It's a technique-based training program,
but without number one and two, number
three is useless.
Without number one and two, number three
is useless.
So, mainly we'll be concentrating on the
techniques.
At the same time,
trying to see to it that you even get
number one and number Without number one
and without number two, number three is
useless.
It may
look very good in this world.
It is
for a very temporary period.
The main success is success in Africa.
So, this training program, how effective
it is
depends more on you than us.
Depends more on you than us.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allah.
>> Amen.